a Florida man says he wants to take
another hang-gliding ride after a
terrifying first light we showed you
yesterday how Chris Gursky desperately
clung on to the glider while soaring
high above Switzerland recently without
any harness attached and well before
Cass spoke with Gursky about his
dramatic adventure he's at a hang
gliding flight park in Davenport Florida
that's just outside Orlando good morning
we are next to a glider here at wallaby
ranch to show you some important parts
you have the harness the carabiner or
clip and the hang strap now Chris Gorski
was wearing a harness during his flight
in Switzerland last month but the pilot
forgot the all important step of
clipping it onto the glider itself Chris
Gorski had never been hang gliding
before but that didn't keep him from
quickly realizing this ride could easily
be his last I was trying to figure out
what was going on and then shortly after
that it was we got a problem here yeah a
big problem yeah curse keys pilot failed
to strap him in leaving the auto parts
manager from Florida clinging to the
glider and the pilot as they sailed
hundreds of feet above the scenic swiss
landscape for two minutes and 14 seconds
when I looked down and I saw the scenery
down there was all the treetops changing
colors the little farmhouses and I
actually thought to myself that is
beautiful I'm gonna fall to my death
there I mean you thought that was it oh
yeah
the pilot tried to land seconds after
takeoff but struggled to get the glider
down instead they climbed even higher at
one point the pilot grabbed gorski's
hand to keep it from slipping off a bar
to be clear here it's not just trying to
hold your own weight on that pole there
you're dealing with the wind and the
speed of that oh yeah I probably had
five seconds left on me when Gursky felt
it was finally safe to let go he hit the
ground at what he estimates was about 45
miles an hour he broke his wrist in the
fall and had a torn tendon in his arm do
you fault the pilot at all you know I I
do and I don't he was actually a great
guy
I felt really bad for him curse keys
wife who took off before him was unaware
of what happened until they reunited
do you regret doing it at all no why not
we were doing what we want to do we live
in our lives we wanted to go hang
gliding and that's so we were there to
do Switzerland Civil Aviation Authority
is investigating and will question the
pilot Chris Gorski says he'd fly again
even with the same pilot in the meantime
the folks here have offered to take him
up this time securely Gayle all right
thank you very much I'll bet his wife
doesn't want him to apply again with the
same pilot
she made it okay she's good I like him a
lot
like mr. ski-doo I don't know if he
should do that again